right
monday night at 8 eastern on c-span 2.
in about 10 minutes on real america a
20-minute u.s agriculture department
film from 1938 titled the negro farmer
first we talked via skype with newcastle
university literature and film scholar
hannah durkin who recently published her
research findings about a woman named
radoshi who she argues was the last
known survivor of the transatlantic
slave trade referred to as sally smith
in the film radoshi briefly appears in
the negro farmer
thanks for being with us on c-span 3's
american history tv and let me begin
with that question who was radoshi
well rido she was a west african born
woman who um
who very very sadly was kidnapped
in 1860 and this was is believed to be
the the last as far as as far as we can
tell the last
survivor of the transatlantic slave
trade um it's believed that she was
yoruba or as far as i could tell um she
was yoruba and she was kidnapped in a in
a slave raid and
and possibly as young as 12 years old
when she was taken
in the film which we are about to see
just a brief glimpse of her and
her name in the film is sally smith can
you explain
yes so she was she was bought by a man
called washington smith in selma and he
gave her his name he gave um it appears
that
four class hilde survivors were um were
bought by him and they all were given
his his name basically and sally i guess
is a kind of it's a diminutive it's a
it's a sort of it's a name that you give
to a child or to a
or to an animal so sort of it's a way of
i guess dehumanizing and claiming
ownership over somebody and what was the
clotilda
so the clatilda was the last spaceship
to reach the us um
in 1860 um it was um for many years
dismissed as a hoax but
an archaeologist actually um
discovered it
in
mobile bay
just
less than two months ago
uh many of the survivors formed their
own community um in mobile known as
africa town or african town originally
and lived there a descendant's still the
best day
and when you heard about that discovery
in mobile alabama what was your initial
thought and what can we learn from its
artifacts
yeah well it's so important it validates
it validates the experiences of the
survivors of the matilda it validates
the experiences i mean the stories of
their descendants
um who are you know sadly it's in sort
of an aging community it's a it's a poor
community
um the community in which um in which
radoshi lived throughout her life and
just outside selma it's also a sort of
you know poor
community so hopefully it can it can
tell us it can tell us about the middle
passages and lived experience and it can
you know give
give voice and
attention to well to both communities
both
africa town and
radoshi's community as well so if you
could take it one step further first of
all where in africa was she born
how did she end up on the ship how old
was he she and what did she do after the
civil war came to a conclusion where did
she live in her remaining years until
she passed away in
1938 well the archival information is
very very limited
um but certainly from what i've managed
to piece together and these really are
fragments it appears that she was
probably from um
basically a yoruba town um in what is
now benin in west africa
um and was kidnapped by
uh
by the dahumian army
um
as a 12 year old i mean the census data
and her own
um
assertions
um contradict one another the census
data is very very unreliable and
certainly at least one census she's
she's
recorded as being um alabama born and
her daughter is her son so it's very you
know it's very difficult to trust it
certainly given the length or
given that she died
in the 1930s it suggested she was very
very young was kidnapped and many half
of the tilde survivors
were children
um but she was so as i mentioned the
majority of the matilda survivors was
were basically sold in the bill and
stayed in
but at least four of them were sent to
selma
um
and throughout her life um
wadoshi lived
in a community called bo pronounced
locally as bogachitta which is just west
of selma
um and obviously she was enslaved for
only about five years because she was
brought to the u.s just before the civil
war
but um she and her husband who was also
a class hilda survivor um had to work as
sharecroppers for the rest of their
lives so ridoche lived in the same cabin
throughout her time in the us
and also she was kind of and some
unfortunately an economic servitude um
to
to the man who bought her and the
descendants of the man
and based on your research which by the
way has been described as painstaking
did she and her husband have any
descendants can you trace any lineage to
those who may be alive today
yes certainly more works more work needs
to be done than i have done but she had
one daughter one surviving child
who
in turn certainly got married her
married name was hunter um
and who she also had children and i
haven't worked out how many children she
had but certainly um
a woman who met her emilia boynton
robinson who was
a leading figure of the civil rights
movement um claimed that she had many
children of many grandchildren many
great-grandchildren who became
teachers and
you know
worked in the church and so and became
farmers as well so there could be many
descendants or there might just be a
handful that certainly
i would think that the descendant's
still living
two final points first for you
personally why did you spend so much
time researching ridoshi and why is it
important for our audience to understand
who she was
well um well basically i mean
i guess i was doing um
a project on zoran l hurst and
i guess i've learned from other people
from other scholars and from colleagues
just how
there is almost no
almost no sort of first-hand
accounts of the mill passage
and
and so when i found when i just happened
to find her name i knew that i knew that
she existed from a letter that saw a
person
but when i happened upon her name i knew
i sort of knew i had to try and
try and have a look to see if i could
find anything about i found much more
than i expected to
um but it's so important to we can we
can never imagine what it must have been
like
to have been taken across the atlantic
to be stolen from your homeland
but i think it's important to reflect on
it and hear the
voices of those who who enjoyed it
and in just a moment we're going to show
the 24-minute film it's titled the negro
farmer released by the department of
agriculture in 1938
tell us about this film and how this
kind of fits into your own research well
certainly i mean there are almost no
there's almost no film footage um let
alone well photographs very few
photographs as well of
a middle class advisor there's some
survivors
of the transatlantic slave trade and so
the film it was basically an
agricultural film that was made
with the intention i mean with the very
paternalistic intentions of
it's it's it's meant to educate and and
help
african-americans southerners farmers
who are enjoying the great depression so
it has a it has a positive intention in
that sense
but really what it's trying to do is
it's trying to persuade them to remain
on the farms to remain in the south at a
time when
there's a great migration north going on
it wants it wants black people to stay
in their place want a better term
um so it's very paternalistic
and it features radoshi very early on to
suggest that
look at how we've helped this elderly
black woman
but of course as a major point in my in
my research in my writing that
um by showing
her what they're doing really is in
unintentionally suggesting that she has
endured and survived and thrived
well before um
there's been any kind of governmental
aid so in a sense they're undoing their
own
um
their own argument really
dr hannah durkin she is an educator at
newcastle university and researching the
life of radoshi which is featured in
this film thank you very much for
joining us via skype from great britain
we appreciate your time on c-span 3's
american history tv
thank you
and from 1938 the film in its entirety
just over 20 minutes courtesy of the
department of agriculture
[Music]
[Music]
there are about nine million negroes in
our southern states and the majority of
them live on farms
while many of these farmers have
achieved independence and perhaps
prosperity all too many barely make a
living in common with all other southern
farmers they have suffered from a train
of evils that have their roots in poor
farming particularly one crop farming
for over 30 years agricultural extension
workers have labored to eradicate these
evils the demonstration work founded
long ago by the late dr seaman a knapp
has grown into a nationwide extension
service this map shows the status of
this work among negroes in 1937
there are over 225 agricultural agents
and about 175 home demonstration agents
now working for better farming and
better living among southern negroes
and sally smith born in africa and long
past her 110th year when she died in
1937 lived to see the hard lot endured
by her generation and that of her
children in some measure bettered by
this campaign to help negroes help
themselves
in the nature of things extension work
among the poorer farmers
living in houses like these on small
farms often on unproductive soil must
deal with fundamentals
thus the problem of the negro farmer is
like the proverbial problem of lifting
yourself by your own bootstraps
he has little or no cash income
it is no mere pleasantly to say that for
these folks the hound dog is a useful
farm animal and that hunting and fishing
are not sports primarily but necessary
means for providing fresh meat under
such conditions the farm agent's problem
is one of making the most of small
resources
here for example is a one-room cabin in
the cotton country
the farm
three acres of thin
sour land
the household
mind you they all sleep together on
pallets in this little cabin
twelve persons
this primitive home this big household
this small thin soiled farm
these exemplify the conditions in
question at their worst
live at home is the watchword of the
extension program and a good home garden
the first objective for otherwise a
proper standard of physical well-being
cannot be attained
here's a well-planned home garden large
enough to supply the needs of a big
family with something left over for
market
another garden farther south where okra
is a garden staple
where it is the practice to can surplus
fruit and vegetables such a garden may
go far towards supplying the family
living
in the truck growing districts many
families make their living from the sale
of vegetables
here is a farm devoted largely to the
growing of eggplant
thus the garden may be expanded to
furnish most of the cash income of the
farm in any event the garden remains a
major feature of the extension program
crop improvement work may begin with a
neighborhood demonstration by the county
agricultural agent
an agent demonstrating approved
standards for the selection of seed core
the lessons learned from such
demonstrations are fundamental a county
agent gives a group of his 4-h club boys
a lesson in seed corn selection in the
field
proof of the value of this work is such
a cornfield as this on the form of a
cooperator
or this field
of corn and soybeans
luxuriant growth of the soil improvement
crop between the rows of course
harvesting tobacco on the land of a
farmer who works in close cooperation
with his county agent in the work that
is being done to improve the methods of
handling this crop
this farmer gives each of his children a
definite share in the proceeds of the
crop these little girls are working not
only for the family but also for
themselves there's wholesome personal
pride back of this dexterity
the help of extension specialists
farmers in the peanut region are giving
more and more consideration to the
problems of handling this important crop
in certain districts the extension
workers have pushed the production of
long staple cotton
a negro family picking sea island cotton
grown from seed secured through the help
of the county agricultural agent
a group of 4-h cotton club boys each
delivering his bail to the warehouse
the success of each of these boys
necessarily has a good effect on the
cotton farming of his neighborhood
these bales are silent witnesses for the
cause of better agriculture
soil conservation is a major feature of
the extension program
farmers are urged to plow and cultivate
on contours and follow other approved
practices
a crew preparing for terrorism under the
direction of an extension agent note
that the job is done with simple and
inexpensive equipment
such modern practice is becoming common
among these farmers as is the use of
soil improvement crops such as soybeans
cow peas lespedeza austrian winter peas
and veg
witness this fine stand of japan clover
on the left the farmer who grew this
crop
the farm poultry flock is a factor of
major importance in the living home
program
these barred rocks provide essentials
needed for balancing the diet of the
household as well as with eggs and
fryers for sale or trade
this flock of rhode island reds is the
pride and joy of a former 4-h club
member
poultry is a profitable demonstration
for both boys and girls and is stressed
as one of the main enterprises in the
live at home program
this 4-h club boy took his chickens to
school with him and with the proceeds
from sale of eggs he is paying his way
at a preparatory institution
a way to get an education if you have
what it takes
in many communities turkeys are a
profitable source of cash income
and occasionally we find a man who goes
into poultry in a commercial way
this is the plant of a farmer who
specializes in white legumes
livestock improvement work is done
largely through the boys and girls 4-h
clubs
some cath club boys getting pointers on
how to judge a dairy cow
and here is the business end of another
4-h calf club enterprise these purebred
jerseys have a high record for butter
fat production
particularly in alabama local
veterinarians with vaccinating equipment
in cooperation with the county agent
have trained many farmers to help stamp
out hog column the farmers in a
community can get the job done quickly
and economically under this plant
these hogs raised by a 4-h club boy show
their good breeding there's profit in
well-bred swine
grade hogs like these from native
razorback sows bred to good bores are
finding a ready sail on local markets
a neighborhood dairy demonstration made
by a girls 4-h club under the direction
of the home demonstration agent
clean milk is a prime objective and
county home demonstration agents
cooperate with the women of their
communities in making all possible
improvements in sanitation in the
handling of dairy products
in communities where such herds as this
are the rules a long step has been taken
toward breaking the regime of fat back
and sorghum under which pellegra has
resulted and become a curse
in such neighborhoods fresh and pure
dairy products are available for all
three times a day
an adequate family supply of dairy and
poultry products combined with
vegetables and fruits from the home
garden helps to safeguard the family
health
clean wholesome farm butter good
homemade cheese and other dairy products
find a ready market when a surplus in
excess of family needs is produced
occasionally a farmer takes to dairying
in a big way witness this big herd which
furnishes grade a milk to a thriving
southern city
in the southern coastal plain the woods
are full of scrubbed cattle the
so-called piney woods breed
negro extension workers there have
inaugurated a better size campaign
breeding for beef with purebred bulbs
here is one of their aberdeen angus
community birds
and here grade cattle produced by
crossing native cows with such bulls
there has been an increasing use of
purebred bulls to improve the quality of
beef for market and for foundation herds
a demonstration in approved methods of
curing pork
home canning and curing of the family
meat supply saves cash
no outlay is needed for bringing home
the bacon where farmers are thrifty and
follow approved meat curing and smoking
methods
a smokehouse is a necessity on the
southern farm for what is home without a
ham
this is a modern concrete smokehouse but
hams from the relatively inexpensive old
time farm smokehouse will smell just as
sweet and stick just as close to the
ribs as those from some more modern
structure the ham is what counts
the sorghum mill
an institution of long standing plays an
important part in the live at home
campaign
the product of this home manufacturing
plant is a staple that goes far toward
reducing cash outlay for food
supplying a cheap suite that has its
place in maintaining the balance desired
in the family diet
furthermore
such a meal often yields sorghum or cane
syrup for sale
thus the livit home program pays
dividends always in saving and sometimes
in cash
home canning of food products is a
fundamental feature of the live at home
program
a well-filled pantry is not only the
best insurance against sickness but it
saves money
a year's food supply for a family of
five in this section may be worth
several hundred dollars since money
saved is money made the women and girls
through such activities as this add to
the farm family income and at the same
time safeguard the family health
a well-constructed smokehouse such as
this makes a good storage place for
canned products in regions where there
is no danger from freezing
these well-filled shells show what the
energetic housewife can do toward
providing the family living
a canning demonstration under the
supervision of a county home
demonstration agent
on such occasions the women of a
community meet and do their work in
common using community equipment while
the agent supervises the work and gives
instruction in approved methods of
procedure where necessary
here is a simple homemade canning outfit
which is used in community canning where
better equipment is not available
a neighborhood canning bee in which the
home demonstration agent directs the
work this is typical of neighborhood
group activity
and here's an exceptionally well
organized and productive community
canning enterprise
once each week during the summer season
the people of this community gather in
this grove to can their products
cooperatively the women prepare the
fruits vegetables or meat products for
canning the men cut the wood keep the
fire going in the furnace and handle the
heavy pressure cookers and everybody has
a grand time
it's a sort of weekly community picnic
that pays dividends in food put up for
winter
shuttered windows with no sash and no
screen are the usual thing in the cabins
of many of the poorer farmers in cold
weather these shutters are kept closed
doors are seldom screened
thus the first step toward providing
better housing is to guard against
disease
to screen out the malaria mosquito and
the typhoid fly
this is a common type of back house
typhoid flies have easy access here
the approved type of farmstead toilet is
not expensive but provides adequate
protection from diseases carried by
flies
after sanitation come other home
improvements that make for comfort and
self-respect many a cabin like this
built in the simple and pleasing
traditional style of the region has been
made a home to be proud of by the
application of a few cents worth of lime
whitewash or even pipe clay that costs
nothing and the planting of a few native
shrubs such improvements take labor but
little or no cash outlay and the results
are sometimes striking watch
now we have an attractive though
unpretentious farm home screened white
washed and landscaped at little expense
such improvements make for wholesome
pride in the home place
indeed beautification of the yard about
the house has a significance that can't
be measured in dollars and cents
when the farm family takes pride in
keeping the farms dead and lawn neat and
attractive
we may reasonably conclude that the farm
business is well managed
where there is a beautiful and perhaps
profitable flower garden the field crops
are likely to be good too
in the south an outdoor bathroom is a
possibility we plug the drain pipe under
the pump the water is pumped directly
into the bathtub and we are ready for
our daily bath
this is a cheap outfit in line with the
extension policy of making the most of
things within your means
of course the modern pressure tank
outfit is better and many farmers are
installing standard plumbing such as
this
this girl is a 4-h club state champion
in dressmaking
all the garments seen here are her own
handiwork
the knowledge and skill that these girls
acquire in this work have a direct
bearing on the family welfare
a successful cooperative curb market
such activities as this represent the
occasional commercial development that
comes from the live at home movement
some of these markets are quite
profitable
a cotton gin
operated cooperatively by a group of
negro farmers under the supervision of
their county agent
the building itself is not much to look
at but the machinery is in good shape
and it does the work
a crowd gathering at a community fair
that has become an annual event
such fairs have both educational and
social features and as a rule they are
well attended
they give extension workers opportunity
to discuss current farm problems with
the farmers of the community and to take
counsel with their local leaders
they also give the girls 4-h clubs an
opportunity to turn an honest penny
through the sale of various articles to
visitors
this is a rather nifty outfit
anyway it seems to suit us
such community activities sometimes are
conducted on a neighborhood scale
witness this modest exhibit of farm
products displayed in a country school
house
such exhibits stimulate interest and
encourage farmers to enter into friendly
competition in production
the extension service sponsors 4-h
summer camps in which short course
instruction in agriculture and home
making is given
these camps are held in slack seasons
boys and girls from all parts of the
state may meet in such a camp the
expense is small and there is
opportunity for study and profitable
association
here boys learn the fine points of their
profession
for example a class in stock judging the
agent drives home the points to be
considered in judging a dairy cow
meanwhile the girls take instruction
from other specialists
here we see a nurse giving instructions
to a class of girls in the fundamental
principles of first aid
of course after study hours there is
opportunity for plenty of fun
recreation as well as study is carefully
supervised
last but not least among these extension
activities are those of this movable
school
operated jointly by the extension
service and tuskegee institute to teach
farming home making and hygiene
here we see the school nurse giving
treatment as a preventive against
infantile paralysis
[Music]
dr booker t washington taught that
agriculture should be the fundamental
pursuit of his race in america
and the extension service tries to help
negroes in their effort to achieve the
objectives he so wisely laid down long
ago
the negro he said must begin at the
bottom
and lay a sure foundation
and not be lured by any temptation to
rise on a false foundation
progress by any other method will be but
temporary and superficial
since the bulk of our people already
have a foundation in agriculture they
are at their best
living in the country engaged in
agricultural pursuits
and again he said
we shall prosper in proportion as we
learn to dignify
and glorify labor
and put brains and skill
into the common occupations of life
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i